foreign
[Music]
welcome everybody I appreciate you
coming to this session
um how's everybody doing
so we're gonna have a panel of these
lovely gentlemen each of them is from
one of our partners
um Executives and the product and
Engineering side of things we also have
a former googler up here as well with
debonjin we'd like to keep this
interactive so there's a my care if
folks would like to come up and ask
questions at different points we're
going to go through a series of
questions but again we'd love to keep
this interactive with this audience
so with that I'm going to kick this off
I'm Claude Robinson I lead our data
analytics partner marketing team and my
team has the luxury of partnering with
these great companies databricks data
robot and mongodb many customers out
there that have deployed the solutions
across these three organizations and um
without going to kick it off with
introducing each of these gentlemen so
first up
we have David Meyer from David didbricks
and we have sahirazam from mongodb
so David tell us a little bit about your
company yeah so I've been with
databricks we were just talking about it
for about six years it was a lot smaller
then
um and you know it's a platform for
doing data and AI together
and one of the main you know it started
off with things like spark and innovated
a lot on top of that but really it's
foundational architecture is what we
call the lake house which is taking all
the kind of abilities of a warehouse and
putting them directly into the data Lake
and with that you can manage all of your
data in one place you don't have to move
it data scientists don't have to work in
a different stovepipe than data
warehouse people and it yields enormous
efficiencies it wasn't possible five
years ago but with a lot of advances it
is and now we work with a lot of the
Google fundamental things like bigquery
on the same formats in the lake so you
can do all of your analytics and machine
learning and llms and generational AI
all of these things in one place so it's
really exciting to be here with uh my
friends
all right and quick question for the
audience how many guys looking at data
bricks today or playing around with it
or touching things show of hands
awesome and feel free to grab me
afterwards if you have any detailed
questions
next up we have debonjin from data robot
so uh you know as Claudia was saying
this is almost like homecoming I was in
Google for uh three years running
bigquery which I hear has now become
bigger and some of the other products
some of the other products which was
like lake has now become big lake but I
have always been a robot and finally
found the right company to work for in
data robot so data robot by the way you
know if you don't know about what we do
we call ourselves the systems of
intelligence it's kind of fancy way of
saying that we sit between the data
layer and the application layer and we
extract Insight from data and we make
applications more intelligent and you
know if you look at double click that
little bit what is that we actually do
there are two fundamental things that we
do one is what I call the AI command and
control center there are a lot of our
customers who have a lot of models built
over a period of time using various
different tools many of them are kind of
in spreadsheets they are trying to
manage them deploying them in various
different environment is not easy and
monitoring them is a pain in the butt
okay excuse my French so what we do is
kind of put all of these things into
electricity history so that people can
manage them from one place we deploy
them in whatever endpoints we want to
deploy them on and then we manage and
monitor them from a single pin of glass
so that's one piece of what we do the
other part of it is essentially building
those models right so there are of
course people have a lot of data and we
feature engineering and feature
Discovery so that we can identify what
are those data points which makes real
difference to people's business then we
build those models and compare them with
various different Alternatives people
have so that they can see which models
works best and then make it available
for deployment so these are the two
pieces of what we do and of course we
work with both data breaks and mongodb
and a lot of our customers have that
data environment and of course with
Google thank you very much same question
to the audience how many of you guys
have been looking at data robot or kind
of kicking the tires show of hands I see
a lot of opportunities
[Laughter]
and the last step we have so here from
mongodb I've been working with you and
your team for a while so tell me a
little about your company so here sure
so uh thank you for having us and thank
you all for joining um I've been with
mongodb leading the product Organization
for seven or so years I originally
joined to lead our transition to the
cloud so I've been lucky to work with
Google Cloud for over seven years in
terms of Shifting our platform from an
open source Enterprise software
technology to a cloud database platform
in close partnership with all the
hyperscalers so for those of you who are
not familiar mongodb is the leading
modern operational data store in the
market today we are in all 37 Google
regions I think that's the most recent
count it's constantly changing and we
really serve developers and you know
with the big wave of generative AI now
pulling ML and models much more to the
Forefront of operational applications
the Live customer experience we're
really seeing a big acceleration of
adoption of our technology and we're
working closely with Partners like
Google databricks and data robot
empowering sort of an end-to-end Loop of
more intelligent applications
thank you and again for the audience how
many of you guys are either using or
kind of checking out mongodb
nice nice
so gentlemen we're going to make this
kind of an interactive discussion
between the three of you so we saw a lot
of discussion today from Thomas and
others around gen Ai and the power of
Genera that we're bringing to
Enterprises
if an organization is kind of driving a
strategy around data and analytics what
do they need to look at when they're
kind of integrating that with Gen AI for
Innovation and growth what are you guys
seeing
who wants to start yeah sure I mean you
know that way I can disagree with you
so the dnai by the way I mean it is the
iPhone moment for the whole world right
I mean AI has been around for a long
time I mean the
people who have been using AI for a long
time but I have never seen something
like this uh in a long long time I was
in an investor conference if you uh
months back Morgan Stanley and every
investor of course asked me about gen AI
on the way back the Uber driver quizzed
me for half an hour about jnai and I
realized that yeah that's when we
arrived he's worried about it replacing
him yeah that's right well you know that
would be a different kind of jai but uh
the power of Jane AI is you know the way
I kind of view this AI of course can do
a lot of things I mean if you look at
predictive AI it has been very very
valuable in a lot of Industries but it's
not easy to explain it to people right I
mean you need some basic knowledge of
maths or statistics even if you automate
everything that's not the case with jnai
it's texting text out people can very
easily understand what it is and it's
also very easy to figure out very very
low hanging you know use cases that can
generate immediate Roi for people right
making essentially the workforce very
very productive and that's what kind of
is so striking about it I mean you know
one of our investors actually always
talk about so what is the boarding
problem you are trying to solve AI of
course solve a lot of very very
interesting problem but Jai can solve a
lot of really boring problem which is
what is driving a lot of business
interest in it on the other end of the
spectrum there is a lot of very very
interest interesting problem scientific
problem which can change the way people
live their lives or many societal
changes can actually come from that that
is also very very exciting and this is
of course a great opportunity for all of
us and I know David you are kind of
waiting for this I mean I actually think
that there is a lot of of course
excitement about models that's going on
I remember you know 10 years back eight
years back everybody was talking about
what algorithm people are using for
predictive AI hyper parameter tuning and
all of this none of those matter all
that much right now I think in another
couple of years which model you're using
is probably going to be less useful and
and I think ultimately people have
access to all the data that they need in
order to train those models yeah
ultimately you know it's actually going
to be how do you create value from these
models mapping the business problem into
AI problem and actually solving it in a
way which creates value for the business
is what's going to be where most of the
action is going to be yeah I I agree in
a lot of is the the joke of of
disagreement was he was saying 20 of the
problem is data and I was saying eighty
percent he's like you're a data guy of
course 95
and 95.
a colleague of mine with a customer
yesterday was describing it as you know
the the the data platforms
you know obviously there's a lot of that
at Google is the cake
and then there's some great cherries you
can put on it which are the models but I
think you're I totally agree with the
bonding that the the the cultural shifts
and how you're applying it
you can do really really dumb things
with llms
you know and you can have a bunch of
like failed projects because they're
just like whims so the and we'll talk
about this more but like the the
obviously you know one problem with llms
is hallucinations but you can change the
training set and stuff like that with
data that's curated to eliminate those
but then you need the data to be right
and that's a lot of the problem of the
Upstream you know so so a lot of it is
getting your data in a place that
everybody in your ward can leverage it
including through llms and then figuring
out all the you know operationalization
of that which is hard
Sarah do you want to add on to that yeah
it's uh one of the things we're
observing it's in you know to do
London's point the idea of models and AI
has been around a long time and
certainly the Gen AI chat GPT boom is
certainly unlocked all of our
imaginations in terms of the
applicability of it and created all this
uh current hype around it but I think in
a lot of ways what we're seeing with AI
and ml is a shift left you know if you
go back 10 years you saw operations give
way to devops and that shift left into
software that automated processes we
then see the same thing happening in
security you're seeing security move
from a centralized security team to be
embedded in the life cycle of
development up front so you can manage
that much more from a development point
of view I think the same thing is
starting to happen with the move from
large-scale training to much more around
real-time inference on the backs of
every development team in all of our
businesses needing to think about how AI
can power these smarter application
experiences so a big part of what we are
focused on is really democratizing the
experience of taking these models taking
the proprietary data that all of our
organizations have which in many ways is
our core value but making it
operationally capable for any team
building amazing software and user
experiences yeah and you know just one
within databricks we classify these into
three categories and you probably do for
your own business okay
okay so there's uh exposing uh you know
co-pilot like chat Bots within
databricks that's one class so we're
exposing llm to the user
we also have a platform so companies can
build their own models and llms so
that's giving them the platform to build
their own tooling and then we also use
these a lot inside totally invisible to
the customer to run better as a company
and those are kind of whenever we talk
about it at e-staff or whatever we want
to say is it you know type one two or
three to classify them same ones yeah
so let me ask you this like if you can
look at the audience and you know with a
different show of hands of different
platforms people are looking at
let's say you know individuals are
trying to implement something at their
company what are some of the key
considerations to look at when you're
looking at different data sources and
different platforms across you know
and Google cloud and data robot
and databricks as they're starting out
so here you want to take that
yeah I think um you know our lens
obviously on the kind of developer or
operational end of the spectrum is how
do we bring the skill set that's
typically been in sort of a centralized
team Walled Garden specialization of
data science or ML and embed that now in
every operating team that's building and
shipping the Production Services and
there's different organizational models
and skill set kind of changes that need
to happen for that but I think to really
Unleash the Power of whether it's gen AI
or just ml more broadly in an
organization I do think it needs to be
viewed as a core competency of a much
broader set of ecosystem even if there
is a domain Specialist Team you know or
the experts so I think focusing on that
getting that whether it's a matrix model
or just building up the skill set Within
These groups certainly is something
we've done internally to enable sort of
the capabilities in our own platform but
as I go up to the 40 000 plus customers
we have and see like the best practice
the most Cutting Edge teams don't view
data science as you know data they throw
over a wall to a team that trains it and
then they get a model that's a black box
back back and then they executed they're
really got that that data science team
embedded just like a designer is an
engineering lead is a product manager is
as part of that core development process
what do you see when you're out there
kind of looking at that consideration to
build on those various data platforms
using these Technologies I I think you
know one of the big problems in
Enterprises are really the data silos
right if you think about you know the
assets an organization has it's their
customers you know various different
physical or non-physical assets that
they have their employees and their I.T
assets right and and typically you have
this vertically Integrated Systems where
all of these kind of siled in various
different systems of records and which
is integrated with the systems of
Engagement
and you get much more value if you can
kind of cut across these various
different silos right so for example you
know you have your data in Salesforce
which is very useful in figuring out if
a particular customer is going to churn
but that customer is also calling the
call center and if they're having
problem with the product I think if you
can map this too you get a lot more
intelligence right and I think that's
what people are trying to figure out how
exactly to do that I mean are they going
to put them in a lake house
that would be one way of doing that I
think you know then they have to keep
doing that all the time and by the way
that's one solution to that other option
would be to integrate them at the
modeling operational data store
and integrate the very modeling there so
that you don't have to move data around
and all of both of these are by the way
yeah
viable good solution so what it really
means that you need a system where you
have open interfaces and open data
format right without that you cannot
really do that and what I would also say
that's kind of a table state for how you
build this composable system right I
mean we also work for example with data
breaks and Google in order to do
deeper product integration so that we
are not just giving people Lego blocks
we fit with each other but also showing
them how to fit them together yep yeah I
think I think standards and abstractions
are two really really key things so we
are talking to I was talking to a large
multinational Bank yesterday
um and they were saying you know they
basically have gone deep in to open AI
right and I was like well be careful
because there will be a plurality of
models we know you know there's Lama two
there's all these other ones and they're
going to keep evolving right and you
might want to be building your own so
you you want to have the right
abstraction
and they said yeah but our developers
say open AI is easy and all the other
platforms are really hard
and that that might have been true for a
minute but now we all have those
abstractions so you can initialize with
openai you can initialize with llama you
can initialize with any type of model
but unless you do that your business is
gonna
get deep tendrils into one model
which will be perhaps Irrelevant for
some of your use cases or or not usable
so the other pieces to the right
standards and the right levels of
abstraction and then
you got to have someone in your legal
department get smart on this stuff
because the problem is it's so easy
that it's so easy to really screw up and
hurt your IP and get yourself into
trouble so you need to have someone
educated in like
legal responsible AI different countries
are having different regimes is that's
going to affect your practices around
these things in the future
yeah we've seen the same thing I mean on
one hand we want to make sure we're
safely consuming all these technologies
that are popping up everywhere and so
you know we want legal we want um I.T
security all the on the governance
process but at the same time we want
teams to be independent and move as fast
as possible because there's so much
Innovation happening right now so
finding a way to kind of have a
centralized group that can at least
share best practices but still not feel
like everything has to be top down
standardized has been a tricky balance
to sort of strike it gets back to
distractions and standards exactly
you're out there talking to customers
like what advantages do you see with you
know kind of Google's core data
platforms and AI with both bigquery and
vertex AI well you know I have of course
a sub corner for bigquery yeah I used to
return that for some time so uh bigquery
is probably one of the best data
warehouses
but
[Laughter]
but there are a lot of customers that we
work with they have their data in
bigquery and what we have done is a very
deep integration with bigquery right so
for example
we have our feature engineering and
feature discovery that we can push down
to bigquery by the way we're doing that
for data bricks also right so that you
don't have to take data out you can
actually do a lot of this filtering work
in terms of what are the important
features which is going to drive outcome
inside the data warehouse itself then
you build the model you can also run the
model within bigquery so that if you
want to do for example batch predictions
you don't have to take it out and then
write it back and not only that I think
the difficult thing in all of this AI
business is really the monitoring aspect
of it right I mean this is what by the
way I believe the biggest issue in jnai
I mean you can ask a question to chat
GPT you get a nonsense answer you can
laugh at it but when you apply that in
an Enterprise setting that's no laughing
matter right and I think it is very very
important important to build those
guardrails and the scaffolding so that
people have confidence in the output
that they're getting it's safe it's
accurate and that's where I see a lot of
collaboration that you can do with not
only bigquery but also with vertex Ai
and we have done some of that and
continue to do that so here with your
company I know you we do a lot with
Atlas you know how this is kind of the
first choice for developers as they're
building new apps and you guys are doing
work with us with bigquery and vertex
you want to add a little bit onto that
yeah I think our collaboration with both
vertex and bigquery has been quite
interesting that you know we're
typically complementary to both in terms
of either vertex sitting on top of
operational data in or
generating all this business data as
part of your application stack but how
do we feed that as a source Downstream
to bigquery or to lake house and we've
got Integrations both ways so that's
been a common sort of architectural
pattern that we've seen these days one
of the newer things that we've been
working on and certainly getting a lot
of demand for is everyone's like how do
I embed AI in my application well the
big hot thing is Vector storage and
retrieval and managing embeddings and
you know the reality is any AI driven
application fundamentally is still at
application it needs transactional
characteristics if I need keyword or
relevance based search or you need time
series capabilities or whatever it might
be and so a big part of what we're
trying to focus on is how do we simplify
the experience so as you're building an
application sure you might need a vector
capability now you may need some search
capabilities but you also may have
metadata or Source data in your core
database should that be four systems or
can we integrate that for a developer in
a much more elegant way and Google's
been a great partner in driving that
into the market and partnering with us
since seven years ago when we started on
the platform
David you want anything under that yeah
I mean I think Google's been there since
the beginning of all of this you know
databricks got created out of Academia
Cal Berkeley creating spark but that was
an inspiration to generalize what they
saw happening at Google to run search
like it's all started back at you know
Google and a handful of other
hyperscalers and then you know you know
all of the initial AI stuff inside to
run Google has manifested into things
like vertex so with all of these things
you need you need scale you need
performance and you need data at the
heart of all of it and that kind of
exemplifies bigquery and uh and vertex
so we work deeply with both sets of
Technologies
um and it's one reason why you know it's
a very fun Cloud platform to partner
deeply with because of all the origins
so like about 10 plus years ago you know
I was kind of this whole in this move of
digital transformation like let's move
stuff to the cloud you guys talked a
little bit about openness like why is an
open data data and AI ecosystem
important to this audience as this next
phase of digital transformation happens
you want to take that one
look
you have data gravity
in the three major clouds all three of
them everybody does and you need to
figure out how to leverage that and
there's a bunch of toolkits on this
stage to help you with that but
fundamentally data has gravity
and for example in these Lake formats so
you have a data Lake and they've been
enriched with things you know we created
Delta there's iceberg there's hoodie all
three of those are great formats for
taking all the data in a lake and
readying it for AI and ml in kind of
these Technologies and the fact is now
they interoperate because of Standards
those standards have increased the value
of so many things people have done
because you don't have to get lock in in
the data itself
and it's it's the core of so much these
days so basically it future proofs your
Investments uh the Technologies
underneath will change the models will
rotate the things you can do on top of
these formats will change vector
embeddings and these kind of things are
going to transform you know a lot of
these applications but you know
working together in in consortiums on
these standards is really important for
example I think there's going to be
standard llm model interfaces so you
know we have our version and data bricks
where you can initialize with open AI or
llama or these other ones but we're
going to standardize that because it's
good for the industry and then all of us
can work on our core competencies and
kind of raise the you know the water and
all the boats here float what's this I'm
saying there
what are your thoughts on so you know I
totally agree by the way I I think you
know one of the things that used to
happen is that you have this vertically
integrated application with data inside
it right and when that happens it's very
difficult to cut across and kind of uh
you know pick the Insight which
sometimes across
resides across this multiple silos right
and the table stake here is really
having a common data format or
standardized data format doesn't have to
be one and a standard API and if you
have that a lot of other things kind of
fall into place one thing I always tell
customers before coming to AI I used to
run databases and data warehouses I
think what you should ask every vendor
that how easy it is to move in and how
easy it is to move out and if you have
those two things nailed I think you have
the portability up wherever you want to
run it and you will pick the best you
know tools or best data where how the
data Lake possible to do that so that's
the key in terms of figuring out not
only the data format and API is the
migration in and out easy for you
yeah I wholeheartedly agree with that I
mean a big portion of why um I think
people choose mongodb is that
flexibility and openness you know the
option of having an open source or a
software version if they have to train
and operate on data that's in the data
center but then having a unified
abstraction across Google and the other
two hyperscalers the ability to span
operational data across those we've seen
a pattern emerge quite a bit now where
you know maybe a application sits on a
primary hyperscale Cloud operationally
serving live users but they want a low
latency replica to tie into something
like Vertex or another upstack service
to be able to run inference or training
on that data we've made a lot of
Investments to make that experience as
seamless as possible to make it easy for
organizations to have that flexibility
and the reality is over the Long Haul
user choice and you know flexibility is
a key consideration for especially large
Enterprise and you know we've been from
our open source routes kind of really
focused on that yeah and I mean the
other key we didn't really mention is
you need that for negotiation leverage
with us
so if we go look at the real world you
guys are out there talking to customers
all the time and while we've been
talking some of the slides have been
showcasing some customers
can each one of you kind of walk me
through a customer that you've talked to
who's kind of deployed a data and AI
solution with your solution Google Cloud
what challenges they were facing before
what were the outcomes they achieved by
implementing this platform so yeah I can
start um I use this one in a recent
mongodb keynote because I think it's one
of the most fun examples we're working
with one of the large automakers you
would all know the name and they're
piloting a project right now where they
record a bunch of sounds of common car
problems across their you know models
and years of cars they vectorize that
and store that in a vector store Engine
with mongodb and the idea then is that
their technicians can record the sound
of a car that has a problem do a
similarity search and figure out what
the com what that symptom is what the
root cause of that's
sound an issue is so it's kind of like
those who have an iPhone it's like
Shazam but for car Diagnostics does that
work for pets yeah
but if you think about it like for this
car manufacturer they've got first party
and third-party technicians across the
globe their Fleet is global so the idea
of shrinking down the diagnosis time
from an hour or two or improving the
accuracy and bringing that down to
seconds or minutes is huge when you
extrapolate the savings the step two is
then saying all right once you know what
the problem is there's a bunch of either
digital or physical manuals that have
the step to step by step instructions
that the technician follows to repair
the issue well now they're vectorized
the full text and that to create a
basically natural language interface so
they can just say hey this is this sound
this is the step-by-step natural
language extension of how you actually
go fix it so that's kind of one of the
most interesting I would say Enterprise
use cases that we've worked with a more
fun one was uh I saw a startup out of
Southeast Asia sign up for our service a
few weeks ago that does personalize fast
fashion so use they use gen AI you give
it a bunch of parameters it'll generate
a shirt for you or pants or whatever
your address and then they tie the loop
with contract manufacturers so it'll
actually go create a version of that
custom piece of clothing and ship it to
you all in sort of a few minutes so it's
taken like the idea of like Zara in
these fast fashion kind of Brands and a
leveraging ad to personalize it all the
way down to the individual they've
already been saying with customers
that's interesting yeah I mean it's
funny because there's a lot you know
there's only certain ones that are
nameable but um you know I think
Google is so foundational from a a
technology perspective we talked a
bigquery and vertex and like for example
uh it was the first place that we used
like a managed kubernetes engine because
the evolution kind of started at Google
and gke was so was so powerful
um and so customers a lot of customers
that are multi-cloud we see a lot of
them bringing more and more gravity to
Google because of these performance
character and what they can do and it's
like uh you know
processes that might have taken 24 hours
before working collectively with both of
our respective Engineers getting it down
to 30 minutes you know going from batch
to streaming because the power of the
technology and the scale is there and
the TCO benefits are are are clear
especially with those reduction of
pipelines
um so like the the the being able to uh
a lot of times you know
there's there's a lot of regions and a
lot of clouds
um and then where where it's possible to
do it in Google with these Technologies
we see people seeing enormous benefits
into banjo so um you know I also cannot
probably name the customer but it's a
major health care provider and by the
way the demo is kind of running in our
booth if you want to go and check it out
I went down to see the logo then I don't
know if we have the logo any kind of a
master logo
the URL
so what they really do two things one is
a triage system so when customers come
into an emergency room the information
about their past visits as well as the
doctor's notes are all stored in various
different Google platforms including
bigquery and we kind of picked that
information from bigquery and the
vectorized version of that from a vector
database and we actually do two things
predict what is the triage level is
whether it is critical or you know other
levels that we have I think there are
five levels and when we have to schedule
that those are the two things that you
come up with and produce a summarized
note for the emergency room doctor
explaining what the issue is and what
are the things from the past visit and
the medical history they need to be
aware of that we generate automatically
and on the way back when or on the way
out when the patients are actually
discharged we predict their readmission
probability How likely that they are
going to be re-admitted and why and then
create essentially a discharge sheet
which tells the patient and the
discharging nurse you know in a nicely
written English paragraph rather than a
lot of
numerical data that these are the things
you have to be careful about and if you
do ABC then it's going to reduce your
probability of getting re-admitted to
the hospital
it's actually a pretty interesting so
that's the Demos in your booth yes come
down see you later
what three general what industries are
you seeing take the most advantage of AI
analytics right now which ones need to
catch up
so the four I mean you know from our
business I mean it's a snapshot not
everybody is probably the same the four
primary Industries we have Financial
Services which is really a Data Business
there's a lot of AIML there and they are
getting more into gen AI
Healthcare retail and Manufacturing
right those are kind of the primary
industry segments that you see but there
are also others for example there is a
lot of AIML used in oil and gas there is
a lot of piml used in telcos for example
so those are the other areas I've seen
yeah it's funny because the the
verticals you just listed were our
biggest for AI and ml kind of until llms
and now there's no it's totally
ubiquitous that's right that is true you
know you can't have a conversation
that's right without addressing that
thing because it generalizes it to
anything humans can do it becomes more
productive yeah that is absolutely
basically the same thing we've seen I
mean certainly Financial Services Health
Care retail I mean fraud and all those
things they've been true for 20 years
been using this right
um I think right now everyone's
interested in it from you know new
startups that are spinning up all the
way to you know established Brands
across every vertical
Lord's recommendation be to the audience
you know if they're looking to deploy
something to kind of scale more
data-driven decisions and uncovery
insights from what they have today like
what what are those steps you would give
them to kind of move forward
so you want to take that one yeah I
think um
I'll maybe take a bit of a controversial
stance on this that's uh mongodbish I
think the idea of getting insights from
your data is boring and 10 years old I
think it's about how you get those
insights and actually turn it into
experiences for your business or your
end customer that allow decisions to be
made faster in an automated way or to
deliver a more delightful customer
experience or to drive a more efficient
business outcome you know I think for a
long time getting insights for your data
men people like me look at a dashboard
and make a decision and that takes you
know a couple hours to a few weeks to
get that Insight now I think it's about
how do we shift that left and really
make that something that everyone can
experience to differentiate in the
market yeah I think you hit on so many
valuables even as a consumer I've in the
past you know doing any type of Stock
Investing I'd go and do my research buy
stocks here and there now they've got AI
Solutions where it'll go and research
every analyst report press release
everything that's out there that I don't
I can't even do human it would take me
years to do and make buying decisions in
real time
I think what we tell customers to start
from value and walk backwards from there
to figure out what is that that you need
to create right whether
um you know it is a business decision
you want to make whether it is asset
pricing that you want to settle or
whether it is for example a triage call
you need to make you have to first
figure out what that business problem is
map it to an AI problem then map it to
whatever data that you need and whatever
ETL pipelines you need to build if you
walk backwards from that value I think
you will see the outcome lot more
quickly and that will make it easier for
people to establish why they need to
spend money on technology right I mean
that has some time become an issue
yeah I mean
again the danger is it's so easy it's so
ubiquitous
you yourself are going to throw it at a
dumb idea just because there's so many
it is it's hard to figure that one thing
that's kind of uh we found is
kind of counterintuitive
that the the less human aspects of the
chat bot things sometimes have
remarkable Fidelity like for example uh
there's there's code that we haven't
upgraded
everywhere because it's life but but but
by moving between like spark versions or
to a data frame API from a rdd API it's
shockingly perfect at so like there's
things that are more mechanical in
nature that have a true answer
that it can be shockingly effective at
it and then it can also be great at the
kind of soft like research type things
which can save people a lot of time but
that's less quantitative
quantifiable so if you pick something
that's more kind of hard skill in nature
which you might not think of llms as
hard skill based you can prove the ROI
so fast that you can get funding for
more similar things and the the training
set is often right there in the in the
public domain we've seen a similar thing
I mean for our business a big portion of
what we focus on is modernizing off of
Old Legacy technology yeah we found llms
really effective at taking a look at old
you know SQL codes stored procedures
stuff that's incision end of life
warehouses the person who wrote it's no
longer even working at the company and
then spitting out sort of a modern
version of that either for it all of our
developers use it to be more productive
yeah yeah that stuff is so powerful for
what role are you guys seeing with
governance and with data management the
new era of AI
us is like sweepingly broad questions
um
well I don't think you can really do it
without AI I'm saying AI inside of your
governance like uh all the all the
archaic ways to crawl data and detective
it's you know PCI Data
are like
so so manually intensive compared to
what you can do with some of these newer
models so like data tagging Discovery
governance seeing people do the wrong
things with data through Discovery and
tagging with llms is so powerful like we
have we have this huge data set in the
system we call log food with all the
Telemetry over time
almost no table has a description
do you know how hard it is to govern a
catalog when no table has a description
you can generate bang on descriptions
using almost no GPU CPU resource in
seconds with these models and your whole
organization gets better now the
governance team
can do their job with a lot more
Fidelity so like just bake it inside
because you have too much data you have
no idea where it is what it is or who
uses it and that problem is a lot more
tractable they are
you know it probably goes Cuts both ways
I think I totally agree with you I mean
a lot of things that we didn't know
where things are and what they are you
can classify them now on the flip side
of it there is probably a lot of data
sitting on various different places
there are sensitive data people didn't
know how to access them search them and
you can actually find them now yeah
right so I think you have to be careful
about how we make it
accessible to people for example if you
just take Enterprise search for example
right I mean you want to create this
embedding and the vector databases and
you know of course various different
data elements are various different
access control and you have to make sure
that the search that you're developing
is also at hold otherwise whatever data
you have available in Enterprise now
through a bot is accessible to everybody
else or in the public domain or in the
public domain right and other side of it
I mean probably a more complicated thing
that people don't know what data these
llms are trained on yeah right and they
inadvertently might expose you to you
know sometime legal issues where they
give answers which probably should not
be available to you right so there are a
lot of tricky issues that you need to
address and that probably is going to
one of the big areas of exploration a
fun little thing databricks did well
first of all we wanted to show that you
could have a lot of Effectiveness with a
small model so we open sources model
called Dali
um but it needed a training set that you
could commercially use right so our CEO
Ali told everybody in the company to
write questions and answers one week and
then we use that to open source in a
commercially viable way this training
set 5 000 questions and answers
um but the funny thing is like people
ask us about Dolly all the time because
it was good PR
um but don't use the dolly model the
dolly model is no good for your real
business applications a training set
though use it you can use it for any
commercial purpose and it's inside llama
because it's very useful so like the the
the the training data is very critical
and knowing being having transparency
exactly what data sets were used to
train the models you're using is
important
well gentlemen I want to thank you all
for your time
um thank you everyone here for sure
these guys will be available for a
little bit if you have questions
thank you
foreign